allora tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo non vi dò io sono fan di j
il nuovo blog ricominciare consiglio
pratico la parata settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da è stata vinta
da roberta che mi ha fatto questo
disegno e me l'ha portato tra l'altro al
raduno che ho fatto ciò l'alzheimer non
mi ricordo e trenta ragazzi in questo
blog vi parlerò di una roba seria che
tra l'altro avete già letto il titolo
sicuro però dopo aver parlato di cose
serie torniamo al cazzeggio totale
perché sempre al raduno che ho fatto
l'altro giorno mi avete dato cose mi
avete dato nelle cose adesso non le ho
ancora viste perché le bacchette rho tra
poco che secondo me e sacchetto più a
picco della vita non ho mai fatto uno
spacchettamento così velo preannuncio
comunque grazie roberta per la fan art e
passiamo alle news allo ragazzi volevo
prendermi un momento in questo blog per
parlarvi di un argomento serio poche
volte mi capita di essere serio e
segnatevi la data che è una cosa
importante allora ragazzi ultimamente
con ultimamente intendo gli ultimi tre o
quattro mesi sotto i video miei e sotto
i video dei mail e pieno pieno pieno del
pieno zeppo di gente chi scrive
raggamuffin dj e name e it's punto di
domanda oppure fai fate entrare fa
vigiani e mail oppure fai j perché non
entri nei mail perchè non fate in tre
dovete stare calmi dovete la calma
dovete stati iniettate vi della tisana
allora fatemi spiegare una volta per
tutte come su caricata anche abbastanza
gaza allora ragazzi mettiamo i puntini
sulle ì finalmente a questa fortuna
domanda che vi fate tutti quanti ma
famiglie perché non entra in e mail
la risposta è no non sono né email se
non succederà che io entrerò name e it's
per un motivo preciso allora io su
youtube
dai dai secoli proprio dai tempi di di
garibaldi nei primi tre anni su youtube
quando è nato fa vige tv ho sempre fatto
video da solo tranne pochissime
eccezioni ma pochissime neanche si
contano sulle dita di una mano e io ho
cinque dita pochissime volte mi è
capitato di fare una collaborazione con
qualcuno questo ragazzi perché io di
carattere sono molto timido essendo
molto timido per me non è
semplice fare un accordo non so se lo
spingi sono più a mio agio se ti faccio
da solo ok tutto questo ragazzi più o
meno iniziato a cambiare nell'ultimo
anno da quando abbiamo iniziato con
social face
ho avuto modo di conoscere di persona
altri creator di youtube tra i quali
appunto in ace con il tempo ragazzi tra
me e mail si è creata una finita perché
ci trovavamo bene nel parlare ci
divertivamo insieme siamo comunque poi
ci siamo sposati abbiamo avuto dei figli
e abbiamo deciso di fare dei video
insieme
e qui arriviamo al punto da quando avevo
deciso di fare dvd insieme la gente ha
iniziato a scrivere perché non entri nei
mesi perché non fate gruppo il fatto è
semplicemente uno quando un gruppo si
forma non sta bene alterarlo se un
gruppo già così ben formato ok io non me
la sentirei mai di entrare in un gruppo
già formato ma poi soprattutto non me la
sentirei mai di fare un gruppo quando
ormai la mia carriera da youtube è già
iniziata da un sacco di tempo
preferirei sempre fare video di norma da
solo ma quando capita fare video come vi
faccio un esempio ragazzi non sono
innocenti di tipo tipo justin bieber che
entra nei one direction c'è che cazzo
succede sarebbe stranissimo c'è una roba
poco strana è un esempio così del
cassone venuto in mente questo scusate
però nonostante questo noi facciamo
spessissimo video insieme quindi alla
fine non cambia cazzo ci alla fine se io
fossi nei mesi non cambierebbe niente se
non che potrei dire a sono name e it's
mi sono rotto le palle di vedere sempre
gli stessi commenti allora lo spiega una
volta per tutte è bello l'ha detto
questo chiudo il discorso
definitivamente per l'ultima volta pace
e amore everyone
passiamo alle cose serie pacquiao voi
non avete idea di quanto è stato
difficile non guardare che cosa c'è
dentro
non avete idea partiamo subito con il
primo oggetto di oggi probabilmente un
pokémon di nuova generazione ma io non
riconosco però è super nioc thank you
every bari per avermi dato questo
passiamo oltre
non è che questa cosa dei pokémon vi
lasciate un po troppo prenderla ma non
vi amo per strada siamo peggio della
peste fumiamo di tutto beviamo di tutto
ska pokemon ricci alla patata ornella
cicero berretto fantastico a parte
abbiamo mano ma veramente no fermi che
qua c'è un upgrade c'è l'upgrade rega
grazie grazie di regalarmi queste cose
che mi rendono più più intelligente di
quanto sembri
basta pokémon che palle panda darth
vader
dopodiché i ragazzi ci abbiamo una roba
in quanto [ __ ] che adesso ve la faccio
vedere che questa lascia di minecraft
praticamente al raduno mi è arrivata una
fan e mi ha detto ti ricordi che in
america non sei riuscito a vincerla bene
te la regalo io ti amo sposiamoci
lo so che tu ti vuoi sposare con
quest'uomo quindi tesoro per me questo
vale come anello dopodiché ragazzi
abbiamo una cosa che io non so neanche
come descriverla sarebbero tipo
caramelle del sushi ma la gag a vedersi
ragazzi è bellissimo c'è anche la salsa
di soia ma come wasabi
c'è tutto cazzo è fantastico e c'è poi
c'è questo qua che il nigiri come fai a
prendere qualcosa non stai bacchette
magiche o apple ha sempre comunque pesce
più fresco dei sushi all you can eat da
10 euro
dopodiché abbiamo con tanto di effetti
sonori uno stormtrooper visto che non
avevo abbastanza cose di star wars gr
grazie a questa quella bandana che ho
messo quando ho cantato cioè i maroni
pieni in live
sì perché io ho cantato ciò i maroni
pieni davanti a tutti quanti avete
presente ad esempio di justin bieber di
prima è coordinate vi justin bieber che
c'è un nuovo talento qua dopodiché
ragazzi cafè questo è bellissimo come
avevo fatto a non trovarlo prima sto
cappello possiamo fare un change che mi
sta ciò kaldor diventato uno sciamano
bellissimo altro cappello questo ce
l'avevo questo ce l'avevo questo da
tigre mi sa che ci avevo pure questo ora
che ci penso quanti cazzo di cappelli
dei figli o questo questo è un regalo il
quidditch attraverso i secoli dio ti
benedica abbiamo altre due fan art della
madonna che faccio vedere lo stesso
perché secondo me meritano alquanto c'è
anche under tail che non ho mai fatto e
mi potreste anche bastonare e c'è anche
la tipa gli inside bellissimo che parla
veramente figo che cazzo è ma come what
a funk una master va fatta così e
bellissima che mario sempre fatto come
che si chiama sosta tecnica e poi c'è
anche la scritta fa vj in quanto figo
grazie zia sei stata fantasma la massa
bocce ciao
rimesso arner ragazzi questo che mi
sembra il becco questo questo preparate
avete presente quando vedete le storie
d'amore quelle troppo sdolcinate che
vorreste spara ecco con tanto di selena
gomez è di 2 milioni con due zeri che
sono le tette di selena gomez
questo è il regalo della vita grazie di
avermi regalato le tele di cushing
grazie passando altre ragazze abbiamo
non uno non due non tre ma quattro album
di figurine dei pokémon questo non è un
album ma per fa vj bellissimo provi a
vedere che il cazzo c'è qua dentro
quando ho iniziato a fare lo
spacchettamento chiunque mi lega non so
se state capendo l'epicità di questa
[ __ ] pagina fitto 4 bella sta carta
sabrina storico invece ce l'ho io non
l'hanno dato a sabrina casa brino
dopodiché i ragazzi abbiamo anche questo
che è un menù saur leggermente forte ma
neanche troppo è questo schema cure e
anche brillantino zoe a 13.000 di vita
non sembra per niente tarocca nafeek you
rende merd pro pokémon a parte passiamo
oltre
sì perché c'è ancora l'altra roman stamm
pensionamento cazzola grossa st busta no
vabbè rega e meraviglioso meraviglioso
quanto figo questo pezzo da novanta
metto qua altri pokémon cappelli mio dio
markin garics una scatoletta fantastica
che ho già aperto quindi non l'ha però
rivolto verso di me ma verso di voi
perché io già figura di merda l'ho fatta
davanti a tutti e la figura di merda è
stata questa
ok c'è perché voi non c'eravate dal vivo
non immagino vedere il mio salto perché
io l'ho aperta così non lo faccio perché
mi cavo in mano però l'ho aperta davanti
alla faccia e stato orribile uno zombie
di minecraft nova ben bellissimo questo
mi mancava ragazzi siamo arrivati
all'ultimo regalo forte penultimo per
ultimo un uovo che in teoria e toni
volete sapere qual è la cosa [ __ ] di
questo uovo ragazzi
è un nuovo finto ma non sembra un altro
foglio di carta con su scritto vuoi mia
sorella e io ho messo sì speriamo sia
figlia un'altra fan art bellina e la
madonna ea tutti fenomeni siete per
ultimo ma non per importanza a [ __ ]
pikachu che è un pikachu borsa e dentro
e pieno di roba
vediamo cosa c'è dentro questa borsa
fantastica che si apre così troppe
caramelle goleador mini frutte cose miti
a mia madre non deve dire questo video
cosa c'è di meglio di un pikachu pikachu
pieno di dolci e spicca su quel pieno di
dolci con le tette ancora meglio però va
bè ragazzi dire che possono concludere
qui è stata quanto strano fare
l'unboxing di tutta questa roba messe
insieme il mio preferito in assoluto a
parte il pikachu rimane questo va bè
ragazzi a dire che possono includere qui
è stato alquanto figo ho preso un patto
di caramello guadagnato pure una sorella
fantastico casi di ragazzi seri del
presunto sono commento è un mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook con video
tedeschi siano cioè sono usciti siete i
cibi chiamano prossimo video e ragazzi